BILL DUANE: Hello, everyone.
My name is Bill
Duane, and I look
after the well being
learning programs here,
which includes the
gPause program.
And today's talk is about
everyday well being and the way
that mindfulness can
be supportive of that.
In particular, during good times
and during challenging times.
It's one of my favorite topics
to hear Noah talk about.
One of the things that's
been really interesting
in my practice has been the more
I learn about my own experience
with well being, even
though the journey seems
very unique and personal
to me, the more I learn
about that really
deeply personal journey,
the more I learn about how
this connects to other people's
and their own journeys.
And so an important part
of the gPause program
is connecting what
goes on here at Google
with what's going on in
the rest of the world.
And in particular, this really
interesting and beautiful way
that we see the connection
between our practice and other
people's.
And particularly during
a time of inequality,
it's really important
to make sure
that there's a connection
between the privileged
and the less
privileged, particularly
in terms of practice.
So that's why, hopefully--
how many people here gPausers?
Yay.
So do you guys know that when
you practice and you record
your practice, it
goes to non-profits
that teach mindfulness to
less privileged groups.
And I have the privilege of
talking about the Mind Body
Awareness Project, which is one
of the groups that we give to.
We all know what's going on in
terms of incarceration rates,
and particularly with kids.
And again, going
back to it, like
what helps the kids
in this situation
is the same thing that helps us.
Sort of self awareness,
self regulation,
and compassion and empathy.
So there's this connection
that's always going on.
So even though today
we're here to practice,
to talk about our own well
being and everyday well being,
it's in conjunction with the
people who are doing this work.
And we have a
number of them here
joining us to let
them know that they're
supported, both directly and
indirectly, by this practice.
And I'll be talking a
little bit at the end
about some opportunities for
volunteering and donations.
But for now, let me introduce
my friend, my teacher,
Noah Levine, author of
books with words in them--
[LAUGHTER]
--on punk rock, well being,
meditation, compassion.
Are you coming out with
a young adult series?
NOAH LEVINE: "Recovery."
BILL DUANE: "Recovery," right.
That's a great thing.
So as I mentioned,
one of the things
I appreciate most about him
as a teacher and as a person
is the ability to
skillfully blend
practice with appreciation,
but also sort of a low bullshit
orientation towards challenges.
And this idea of turning
towards challenges, as
opposed to turning away from it.
So with that, I introduce
to you Mr. Noah Levine.
[APPLAUSE]
NOAH LEVINE: Thank you.
I'm happy to be here and
especially happy to be here
for this conversation
with you, but actually
in support of the Mind
Body Awareness Project.
And I'm not at all used--
although I speak quite a bit,
I'm not used to standing up.
I'm used to sitting down and
sitting on a meditation cushion
most the time when I'm teaching.
Or at least in a chair.
So I'll stand here
awkwardly and not
really know what to do with
my hands, and figure it out.
So a little background
of my experience
that brought me to
mindfulness practice
and that eventually
led to establishing
the non-profit of Mind
Body Awareness Project
was that I probably
was introduced
to mindfulness as a child.
My father was actually
a mindfulness meditation
practitioner and teacher.
And so it was modeled,
like I saw my parents
meditating when I was a kid.
And I was somewhat
aware of meditation.
But through my own suffering
in childhood, and confusion,
and pain that I
experienced, I completely
rejected, or just
wasn't interested
in-- it was modeled,
although I just
wasn't interested in
anything healthy for me.
I was interested in
destruction and intoxication.
I wanted to escape reality.
I didn't want to sit
mindfully in reality.
I want to avoid it.
And found lots of
different ways to avoid it,
and lots of experiences,
which eventually for me
led to drug addiction and lots
of crime and incarceration.
And at 17 years old, sitting
in Santa Cruz County Juvenile
Hall, where I grew up.
And I'd been in and out of this
juvenile hall quite a bit from,
I think I was about 11 years old
the first time I got arrested.
And just kept getting in
trouble and this sort of cycle
of recidivism and in and out of
the court system and juvenile
hall.
And this moment of desperation
in my life, where there
was a huge shift for me from
that first portion with all
of that trouble.
And I just blamed everyone else.
I didn't take any
responsibility.
I felt maybe justified
in my actions,
and somewhat like a victim.
Like I was-- it was society's
fault. It was my parents.
I love to put it on the hippies.
It was the hippies' fault that
I was an angry, violent, drug
addicted punk rocker.
I had to rebel
against my parents.
But I found myself in sort of
a desperation and a realization
this last time that
I was incarcerated,
where up until that time, I
had felt like, like I said,
it was everybody else's fault.
And I felt really stuck.
My father had
probably encouraged
me to meditate a lot
of times, but I'd never
really considered it.
I'd never seriously
considered it.
But there was this moment
where I had a suicide attempt,
and I was in a padded room,
and an observation cell.
And I got a phone
call from my father.
He didn't live locally.
He was out of state And he
said, would you like some help?
And I was like, yes.
I need a lawyer, totally
get me some help.
I'm in big trouble.
Get me some help.
And he said, are you ready
to learn mindfulness?
Are you ready to
practice meditation?
And with a little bit
of disappointment,
but with the desperation
of nothing else worked,
nothing else that I've
sought happiness or well
being or contentment through--
drugs, violence, crime, sex,
attention, all of the
adolescent ways that I thought
would maybe make me happy.
It all failed.
I was in this sort
of like failure.
So I was like, it's
gotten this bad.
I'll even try meditation,
I'm this desperate.
[LAUGHTER]
I will even try meditation.
And right from the
beginning of mindfulness
practice, and I was given the
simple mindfulness instructions
that most people are given
in the beginning, which is
pay attention to your breath.
I think something
like, breathing in,
know that you're breathing
in, feel the breath entering
the nostrils.
Breathing out, know that
you're breathing out,
feel the sensations.
And ignore your
mind for a moment
and pay attention to your
breath and your body.
And that was a long time ago.
A little over 27 years ago.
I don't completely remember the
conversation or my experience,
but some way or another, I
got willing, I got inspired,
and I went back to my cell,
my juvenile hall cell,
and started trying to meditate
with this simple-- actually,
I think the other instruction
that I was given was count.
Breathing in one, breathing
out two, breathing in three,
breathing out four.
And I would kind of
go one, two, and then
be gone, just
thinking about prison
and what that was
going to be like.
Or this sort of shame
of the past and regret.
Just all of the suffering
that my mind was creating.
Like being locked in a
cell is unpleasant enough,
but actually, my mind was worse.
The past was way worse
than being in that cell.
The future was way worse,
my fears way worse.
So I immediately got some
relief, some level of relief.
What a relief to not be
in my mind, even just
for half a breath, even
just for that in breath,
even just for that out breath.
Just that little
moment of avoiding
the suffering, the
psychological, mental,
emotional suffering.
And being with
the-- which was also
a pretty unpleasant
experience for me.
At the time I was detoxing
from alcohol and drugs.
It wasn't like all of a sudden
I'm meditating peacefully
in this jail cell.
I'm really unhappy.
But even my unhappiness
that the mindfulness,
from the beginning,
I saw this is
better than what
my mind creates,
the suffering that
my mind creates.
My first couple of
years, I ended up,
I was locked up for a few months
and then put into a group home.
And I got very lucky.
I could have-- it was
the '80s, and they
weren't sentencing adolescents
to adult prison yet.
And the three strikes,
all of that stuff they,
weren't doing that for kids.
And it was actually
my third felony arrest
that I was in for that time.
And I could have-- 20 years
later, I could still--
kids that get
arrested for the stuff
that I got arrested end
up for decades in prison.
But the timing and
fortunate lucky karma, I
don't know, something.
I ended up having a judge
that said let's just keep him
in a group home
until he turns 18,
since I was still an adolescent.
I meditated.
I tried to meditate.
I didn't really know
what I was doing,
but I tried to pay
attention to my breath.
And I tried to ignore my mind.
But I was very
embarrassed about it.
Meditation's not cool
where I come from.
I wasn't going to tell
anybody that I was meditating.
Luckily, I was mostly
in a single cell.
And then I was put
into this group home
where there was
like four teenagers
in this room in bunks.
And then I'd have to kind
of lay there and pretend
like I was sleeping as I was
doing breath awareness, or body
scan, or kind of-- I'm not being
weird, I'm just laying here.
Kind of stealth, secret
mindfulness practice.
[LAUGHTER]
And my meditation practice
was pretty half-assed
for the first couple of years.
I didn't get serious
about meditation
until I was about 19.
Late starter.
First couple years I did
it, and I think I used
mindfulness the way that a lot
of people maybe use prayer.
I've heard of the, I think they
call it the foxhole prayer,
when things get really bad.
Then you're bargaining with God,
like get me out of this one.
I won't do it again.
And I would use mindfulness
like that, when I got really
stressed out, really
afraid, really
shame spiral or something.
And I'd come back to my breath.
Like ignore that, come
back to my breath.
And then at about 19 years old,
I think that a piece for me--
I don't know how,
and I'll try to get
into the core of the
conversation here.
But I still have this idea
that maybe the happiness
that I was seeking would come
somehow from outside of myself.
I still had-- I was like
well, I'm a drug addict.
If I'm sober, then
I'll be happy.
If I have money, if I
have a relationship.
I just kept thinking that
somewhere out there was
the happiness that I sought.
And I found myself just
two years later-- I
got my GED, went
back to college,
had the car that I thought
would make me happy.
I wanted the low rider.
I got it.
I wanted a motorcycle.
The beautiful girlfriend.
I was like, I had all
of the material stuff
and sensual experiences that
I thought was going to work.
And I was so disappointed
that it didn't work.
I was so disappointed
that I signed up
for a meditation retreat.
[LAUGHTER]
Well, I also got busted by
the police for graffiti.
Sober vandalism, out
there ego trip tagging.
And I got in all
of this trouble.
And it was meditation
that was like, oh, this
is the only thing that's
ever really worked.
This is the only
place I've ever found
any true inner satisfaction
or feelings of well being.
That the stuff, the
sensual, the material never
really satisfied me.
And so I started going
to meditation retreats,
and practicing
daily, and getting
more disciplined about it.
And moving beyond the simple
breath awareness, kind
of ignoring my mind practice,
and was instructed in actually
expand to your whole body.
And expand to the
emotions, and feel them,
and start watching your mind
rather than always ignoring it.
Being mindful of all of
the experience of being,
rather than just using the
breath as a stable object
that allows us to
avoid the thoughts.
Although in the
beginning, that's
very important as all
of you meditators know.
But the instructions expand.
And not only the
mindfulness practice,
but also the heart practices,
the compassion practice.
And forgiveness meditation was
a huge important foundation
for me.
I had so much self-hatred
and so many resentments.
And so training my
mind, and forgiveness
phrases, and compassion
phrases, and loving kindness,
and equanimity.
All of these
different meditation
techniques that I
was introduced to.
Mindfulness being core for sure.
But the emotional
intelligence as well.
And not just the wisdom, not
just the mindfulness wisdom.
So I go very serious
about meditation.
And then it just made
sense to me a few years
into my own meditation
practice to start
going back in to
the juvenile hall
where I had been locked up.
And really out of the gratitude
of, oh, this really worked.
My life not only externally,
but really internally,
my life changed so drastically.
I felt so grateful.
I finally came to a sense of
more sustainable, ongoing well
being.
Being comfortable
in my own skin.
Being at ease, whether it
was pleasant or unpleasant.
Mindfulness taught
me all of that.
And it all went back to
that moment of willingness
in juvie that
started my practice.
And so sometime
in the mid '90s, I
started going back into
the same juvenile hall.
Actually, I'd imagine
that many of you
are familiar with the Wisdom
2.0 conferences, and Soren
Gordhamer who has
organized that.
And Soren and I were friends.
And we started the juvenile
hall meditation groups together.
Started going into
Santa Cruz, and then we
are going into San Mateo
and teaching meditation
to the kids.
And I'd get in trouble
once in a while
because trying to relate to the
kids, I'd be like mindlessness.
It's like you're
rolling a joint.
Like you're paying attention
and you're like taking out
the seeds and the stems.
And I'd try to use these sort of
street analogies with the kids.
And sometimes the guards would
be not so happy about that.
[LAUGHTER]
But the kids totally got it.
They're like, yeah,
I know what that's
like when I'm really
paying attention
and I'm trying to get
the seeds and the stems.
And I'm trying not
to break the paper.
And that's the only time
I'm really paying attention.
So yeah, do that to your breath.
Pay attention to your breath.
It was a pretty wonderful
experience actually going back
into that same juvie, and
kind of full circle for me.
And then a few
years later, when I
was going to grad
school in San Francisco,
some of the guys that were
in graduate school with me
knew that I was doing
the meditation groups.
And they said hey,
let's start a nonprofit
and let's do this more.
Let's do more meditation groups.
Let's expand it to San
Francisco and Marin and Oakland.
And we got a grant
from Thich Nhat Hanh
that helped us start the
Oakland meditation groups
in the Oakland Alameda juvie.
So as an, I know,
long introduction,
but it's so wonderful for me.
Because then I became
a psychotherapist
and I began being a full
time meditation teacher,
and writing books about
it and all of that.
And I turned MBA over to
the people that were still
going in, and I went on and
opened a meditation center
in New York and San
Francisco and Los Angeles.
And went this other direction
then in doing the juvie work.
But always was a little
bit of connection to it
and staying in
board of advisors.
And then last year,
of really seeing
that the organization
was struggling, really
struggling financially,
of saying, how can I help?
How can I help raise some money?
I want this work to continue.
Make sure that kids in juvie
get introduced to mindfulness.
So it's such a joy to
be here on their behalf.
And now let me try to shift
a little bit into the topic
of everyday well being.
I mean, I guess the simplest
way to talk about it,
and it's a big shift
for most of us ,
is to come through mindfulness,
through present time,
nonjudgmental,
investigative awareness.
Which would be one
of the ways that I
would define mindfulness.
Present time, no
judgment of what's
happening in the present.
Some level of investigation.
I think that there can
be a confusion often.
We say mindfulness, and we say,
well, let's ignore our minds.
And then we think, people think,
oh, I can't use my mind then
to investigate what's
happening in the present,
because that's thinking, right?
But actually, there's a
quality of mindfulness
that is reflecting on what's
happening here and now.
Of investigating and looking
deeply, and even thinking
about what's going on,
what is this emotion,
what is this sensation,
what is this thought?
Of an inquiry and
an investigation.
The appropriate use of
thought in meditation.
Not just always ignoring
our minds forever,
but using them, training them.
Maybe even turning
the mind into an ally.
The wisdom that gets
developed and uncovered
through mindfulness.
And I feel like
what I wanted to say
about that was that through
this experience, beginning
to understand directly and
deeply that our happiness,
or unhappiness, our well
being, just like me sitting
in that juvenile hall
cell, it doesn't really
depend on what's going on.
Now whether it's a really
difficult experience that's
happening.
Or I've also had the experience
when my first book came out
and it was on the
best sellers list.
And that was like so exciting.
I wrote a book and it's
on the best sellers list.
But I was in this relationship
that wasn't going very well.
And just seeing
this sort of like,
I'm supposed to be really happy.
I'm kind of miserable.
I'm kind of not-- I'm
not getting my way.
Things aren't going
as well as I thought.
Or just that disappointment.
I thought I'd be happy.
I thought that success and
sobriety would be the solution.
And then always having to come
back to the inner well being.
And that it's not
about what's happening,
whether it's pleasant,
unpleasant, or neutral.
But that it's how
am I, how are we
relating to what's happening?
Whether it's really difficult,
or it's really wonderful,
really good, really pleasant.
Kind of a big example
of that-- and maybe, I'd
imagine some of you have
had that experience--
I was meeting with a music
producer a few months ago who
wanted to learn to mindfulness.
And asked me to talk to him.
And we were talking about
his first platinum record.
And he said it was like
the worst day of my life.
He was like, I thought it would
be the best day of my life,
but for some reason, it was
just crushing that it happened,
and it happened
early in my career.
And I just feel like there's
nowhere but down from here.
The bar has been
raised, and just
what his mind did
about his success.
He went on to ask me a question.
He has about half
a billion dollars,
or something like that, and we
went on to ask me a question.
He said, some of my
friends are really rich.
[LAUGHTER]
Some of my friends
are billionaires.
And I only have half a billion,
so I'm not-- compared to them,
I'm not that rich.
And he said, and none
of them are happy.
He said, I have
all these friends
and they're billionaires,
and we go on the yachts,
and we go and do this stuff.
And none of them are happy.
And he was somebody who
had realized that earlier,
that the money wasn't going
to work for his happiness
and turned towards
meditation practice.
And was saying, yes, I do that,
and I make all this money,
and I do music, and
it's my passion.
And I know that I have to
take inner responsibility
for my well being, and
not the next success.
And not the next platinum
or whatever record.
And that's the core, right?
That's the simple
and core teaching,
which is that our well
being isn't about what's
happening outside.
It's about how are we inside?
Have we developed
the compassion,
the care for our own pain,
for our own difficulties,
for the stresses that
we inevitably will face?
And have we developed the
non-attached appreciation?
Knowing mindfulness so quickly
shows us, oh, everything's
impermanent.
Everything's
constantly changing.
But I want the
good stuff to stay.
The clinging, the attachment.
I want everything that's
pleasant, like don't go,
don't be impermanent.
How dare you.
If it's unpleasant, please,
yes, be impermanent.
I'm happy to let
go of this pain.
But the pleasure not so easy.
The successes, the
heights, the good times,
not so easy to let go of.
Now, I have a sense
that-- I'm a poker player.
I like poker analogies, that
the deck is stacked against us
for happiness as human beings.
That the survival instinct
that we're born with.
Everyone, not just
really messed up
kids like me that become
drug addicts and criminals,
everyone, that we're born
into this body that clings all
by itself.
That constantly
craves for pleasure.
That we all have a mind
that's planning mind,
planning, planning,
comparing, judging, craving.
That it's our survival instinct.
That it's that reptilian part
of the brain from the millions
of years of evolution.
Mindfulness is really
this radical tool
that not very many
people have, that
teaches us about
letting go and accepting
the impermanent nature, rather
than clinging and craving
and chasing the next fix.
The next pleasure, the next
success, the next promotion,
or whatever it is.
Now, that having been
said, also mindfulness
gives us a way to say, oh, I
do want the promotion actually.
I do want to be successful.
I want to be healthy,
maybe wealthy.
I do want all of that stuff.
And how can I pursue my goals
without suffering about it
too much?
How do I work for satisfying
the healthy desires
that I have without the
stress and fear and suffering.
Mindfulness teaches
us that directly.
I think in the writeup, Bill
and I were going back and forth.
He's like, it's
a little vanilla.
Let's make it a
little bit edgier.
Whether the shit hits
the fan, or what was it?
Whether you're feeling
you're kicking ass in life,
or life is kicking your ass.
And that with mindfulness,
sometimes life
does kick our ass.
And can we maintain some
level of well being,
even in the difficult times.
And my experience with decades
of mindfulness practice
is that I'm fairly
successful most of the time,
even when it's really
difficult. And I
do have some difficulties.
And then when life
is really good,
and the inflation, the ego
wants to take it all personal,
that mindfulness says, oh,
this isn't so personal.
Just pleasant attention.
Don't believe
those ego thoughts.
Don't believe the stories
that the mind wants
to make up about
oh, it's just going
to keep getting
better from here.
Kind of staying grounded
in all things will pass.
All things will change.
So maybe, let's see what
kind of questions, dialogue.
I'm happy to talk with you
about anything you'd like.
Any questions about mindfulness,
other meditation techniques.
Anything that I've said.
Any questions about MBA.
We're going to talk about
that a little bit at the end.
But for your meditative
practice, for your mindfulness,
or compassion, or forgiveness.
Whatever it is that you're
working on or getting
inspired to work on
in your own efforts.
What kind of thoughts,
questions, or comments
do you have?
Please.
AUDIENCE: My name is Genevieve.
Nice to meet you.
NOAH LEVINE: Nice to meet you.
AUDIENCE: My question is around
transpersonal experiences,
like really elevated
experiences of consciousness.
Did that play in your
meditative journey?
And where do sort
of place those?
NOAH LEVINE: Both on
drugs and not on drugs.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: I don't know
if you can repeat that.
NOAH LEVINE: Do I need to
repeat the-- the question was
about-- she said
transpersonal, elevated,
expanded senses
of consciousness,
and did those play
in my journey?
And maybe how important are
those experiences maybe?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
NOAH LEVINE: And I don't know
if that's really your question,
but that's the part that
I'm interested in answering.
[LAUGHS] And I'll try to
answer the first part, which
is it seems like in
the meditative process,
there are many different
ways that it happens.
There are some people who have
these very big, expanded kind
of awakenings and insights.
And it's kind of life
changing experiences
that happen through meditation.
Really seeing some stuff
you didn't see before.
And understanding your
mind in a way that's
the ego, the self,
whatever you would call it.
Like there are some big,
transpersonal experiences
that happen for some people.
And there are other
people that will
meditate every day
for decades and never
have any of those big,
bright light, bells
and whistles
meditative phenomena.
And so there's a conversation
in the meditation circles
and community about the
spontaneous insights
or the gradual awakening
process that happens.
Of becoming more and more
clear, more and more present.
But it happens slowly, and
it's no big experiences.
It's just, oh, I actually pay
attention more consistently.
And I am compassionate
more consistently.
And I'm forgiving more easily.
And I've become generous.
And it just sort of
happens very gradually,
rather than a big, expansive
experience that led to it.
I tend to see my own
meditation practice
developing pretty gradually.
For instance, I
would do some of what
I call heart practices, loving
kindness, or compassion.
And for the first
couple of years
that I would do those
kind of practices,
I didn't even mean it at all.
[LAUGHTER]
Like I would say to myself,
may I be happy, may I be kind.
And my inner voice
was so unkind.
It was just like,
this is bullshit.
But I kept doing it anyways.
I persevered.
I had found in
mindfulness enough relief
that I wanted to really follow
a meditative path in my life,
even though some of
those other practices
just felt like, this is just
making me more agitated.
This isn't making
me calm at all.
This is just showing me
how angry and afraid I am.
But then after a couple
of years of looking back,
and say, oh, I
actually mean it now.
And after five years of oh, I
actually mean it and feel it.
How did this happen?
I'm not judging my own inner
meditation voice so much
anymore.
10 years of just really
gradually looking back
how it worked slowly.
And then I also have done
some really long meditation
retreats, like three month
silent meditation retreats.
And on those-- and one
month, and three months,
and lots of 10 day
meditation retreats.
On those sometimes I
got so concentrated
that I had some of those
really weird expansive,
might be what we
call transpersonal,
disillusion of everything.
And pretty weird
meditative phenomena
can happen when you're
practicing all day, every day
for weeks or months on end.
But my teachers were always
very-- a little bit dismissive
of that phenomenon.
They were a little bit
like, oh yeah, that's OK.
Yeah, dissolved into
rainbows, whatever.
[LAUGHTER]
OK.
They would really just be like,
can you pay attention to that?
Can you note that?
Is it pleasant or unpleasant?
Are you clinging to it?
Rather than putting
much emphasis
on those big
meditation phenomenon,
just like, just phenomena.
Pay attention to it
like you pay attention
to the breath or the
motions or the mind.
You don't have to push it away,
but don't get attached to it.
Don't think that that's
like the real thing.
Just part of what happens.
And a lot of people have
suffered a lot about--
and maybe even some of you.
I know I've done it some.
About like, you start
meditating and you
have a pleasant
experience back in 1974.
It was like, that was so good.
And then you spend the rest of
your meditation practice trying
to get back there.
I want that one again.
I felt good once,
and I want to do it.
And then you kind of
suffer about trying
to create an experience,
rather than what
the core of mindfulness is,
which is accepting what is,
as it is, pleasant or
unpleasant, expanded
or contracted.
One of my meditation teachers
likes to, over and over,
say right now, it's like this.
And that's the mantra.
That's the-- whatever.
It's like this, and it's
fun, or it's painful.
It's like this.
It's joy, it's
sorrow, it's boredom.
It's like this.
That radical
acceptance perspective.
Was that close enough
to what you were--
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
NOAH LEVINE: Thank you.
I liked your comment
about speaking
the language of the people
that you're teaching to,
that you're talking to.
And how important that is.
You know, I like
teaching with Bill
in this kind of environment.
And we've done some
things together.
Because he knows the
language of Google, and how--
and I could try to do
some computer analogy
that I would just botch.
Like I just, I don't--
But it's important,
and I think that Google has
actually been great at doing
that, and empowering people
from within to do the gPause.
So that you're speaking to
each other in your language,
rather than bringing all
outside facilitators.
And for the latter part,
I feel like actually, I'd
like maybe Micah to
speak to that question,
because he's like one of
the core facilitators who's
doing it now.
And I feel like, actually,
if I went into the juvie now,
I'd be a little bit out
of touch with the youth.
When I was doing
it 15 years ago,
I felt like I was
much more connected.
But now I'd feel
a little bit less.
I would do it, and I'd try.
And there's a
universal language.
But I'd be curious,
what would you
say to that, of kind of
the entry point of what's
working best, and
what techniques
are you using that are-- yeah.
Micah's one of the core
instructors, and does a lot
of the classes around the bay.
MICAH ANDERSON:
So, yeah, welcome.
My name's Micah Anderson.
I'm the senior meditation
instructor at MBA.
We have the 10 to
12 module curriculum
that we use with the youth.
The first kind of
foundational one
is introduction to mindfulness.
So for example, the way we would
introduce that to the youth
would be through a game called
Still Chillin', which is,
essentially it's a competition
to kind of see who can sit
still the longest.
And generally, a class
would be 8 to 10 kids,
somewhere around there.
And slowly, we'll play like
five or six rounds sometimes.
And slowly we'll start to
introduce some instruction
in the actual game.
And it's a great way for them
to start to find just focus.
Usually it's a visual, right?
They'll find a piece and they'll
just kind of sit and just
focus on it, right?
And then slowly people
will start laughing
and get knocked out.
And there's always like last
man standing kind of thing.
And then as the curriculum moves
forward, and a lot of times
we have a cohort model,
which we'll move through.
And each module builds
on the next one.
So we'll talk about
basic goodness.
And then the next module would
go into impulse regulation,
just kind of unpacking how
mindfulness can support
impulses and reactivity.
And the difference between
a reaction and a response.
And then it really
starts to go deeper.
We do start to go into things
like emotional intelligence
and awareness, and how we can
use that self moment to moment
presence to look at emotions.
And then eventually look at some
difficult emotions and trauma.
And will impact what
empathy is, and compassion,
and try and unearth
beliefs that the youth may
have about themselves,
whether negative or positive.
And then trying to
address those if possible.
So those would be
some of the areas.
And we use loving
kindness meditations.
We use a variety
of different types
of body-based meditations.
Mindfulness of breath.
Of course, the counting
one is very good.
Because the youth, they're
dealing with things
like they can't fall
asleep at night.
And they're stressed about
their court case in the morning.
And they're separated from loved
ones and their communities.
The majority of the
youth that we're
serving in San Mateo
as well as Alameda,
they're carrying a reasonable
amount of trauma and PTSD
that really is affecting
their ability to do a lot,
to do anything in a certain way.
So does that kind of
help answer the question?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
MICAH ANDERSON: Thank you.
NOAH LEVINE: So the
question was that part
of what will happen for
people in meditation
is that there will be different
levels of pleasant experiences
that Meng is pointing
to of joy will start
to arise in the meditation.
Uplifting joy, he
was talking about.
Or this kind of calming
happiness and gladness
that will happen.
And then what's the
connection between that
and emotional pain?
And I don't know that
I know the answer.
I don't know that I know
the answers to that.
I have directly
experienced a lot of really
pleasant meditative states.
And what we call
the rapture states.
And especially on
those long retreats
when you get really
concentrated,
and all of the stuff
starts to go away,
and this joy and
happiness comes.
And of course, it's
all impermanent, right?
It comes and it goes.
It passes.
I don't know the
answer to how it's
connected to emotional
pain, because I also
have had so much emotional
pain in my experience.
And I think-- I tend to
think that emotional pain is
unavoidable for all
of us human beings.
That it's just part of having
a mind , having a heart,
having emotions.
That we have unpleasant,
afflictive, emotional pain.
And some people have the
deep traumatic experience
that Micah was talking about
with many of the students
that we're working
with in the juvies.
Maybe some of us.
I know myself, I've had a
lot of traumatic experience
in my life, and a lot
of emotional pain.
But I don't know how or if it
equates to the development.
I tend to think of
the phenomena of joy,
rapture, that that is a
universal outcome of training
the mind.
That in a deep
meditative discipline,
you get concentrated enough,
it's just what happens.
Joy will arise.
Gratitude, gladness, these
pleasure states will happen.
And I would imagine
that whether or not
you've had a lot, kind of an
extra dosage of emotional pain,
or actually you've had
a life that hasn't had--
you've had the normal
human suffering [LAUGHS]
that we all have.
But it hasn't been
extreme in any way.
I'd imagine that there--
I feel like-- I don't
know if it's true or not, but
I feel like those are just
sort of universal
qualities that happen
as part of the phenomenon of
deep meditative discipline.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Can I [INAUDIBLE]?
NOAH LEVINE: Yeah, please.
And I'd be curious
what you-- I think
you have a thought
about that that I
haven't thought about yet.
AUDIENCE: In your journey,
which very touching
journey of managing pain, your
emotional pain, at what point
did your ability to-- I'm
guessing at some point
you developed the
ability to access joy.
And at what point
did that become
helpful as part of the journey
towards overcoming pain?
And if so, how so?
NOAH LEVINE: It's
hard for me to answer
because, like I was saying
in that first question,
it happened so gradually for me.
I can't point to, like oh, and
then there was this moment.
But I do, reflecting
back, and say, oh,
those first couple of
years I was doing the-- I
wanted the kindness
or the compassion
or the joy, the
appreciative joy,
but it wasn't really happening.
I wasn't even able to,
in my own inner voice,
be sincere about what these
well wishing practices.
But at a couple years,
started to shift.
At five years into my
practice, I could see it really
starting to shift.
I can remember about 10 years
into my meditation practice
where I had the experience
for the first time
in my life of
forgiving everyone.
Up to that point,
I had resentments
that I was trying to let go
of, but hadn't let go of.
I had made some progress,
progress, progress,
but there was still those couple
that we're just no, not yet.
And then coming to this moment
about 10 years into meditation
practice where I'd forgiven
everyone, including myself.
And I could think of even the
worst people in the world,
I could think of them
with some compassion,
with some forgiveness.
And seeing them as
suffering, confused beings.
And that was joyous.
And I can remember that.
But I can also-- it was an
interesting experience for me,
because there was also a
delusion of permanence.
I thought, I'm done.
Forgiveness, did it.
[LAUGHTER]
Totally done.
And then I was a little
bit surprised the next day
when I was pissed off again.
I thought I was done
with these resentments?
I thought I'd forgiven.
And then see, oh,
even that forgiveness,
even that joyous experience
of liberation from hatred
was temporary.
It was real, but it
was really impermanent
like every other mind
state or emotion.
So for me, pretty gradual.
Sometimes it's hard to tell,
also, inside ourselves.
Other people might
be able to-- Micah
might be able-- me and Micah
have been friends for 25 years.
He might be able to say, yeah,
around seven years he was less
of a jerk.
He was happier or whatever.
Sometimes the people outside
of us can say, you're happier.
And inside, we're
not always totally
clear about when that happened.
How do we navigate the balance
between generosity and kindness
and compassion and forgiveness
and healthy boundaries?
And when it's too
much, overtaxing on us,
or I think you ended with
then we're resentful.
Like we've been too
forgiving, and we're not
taking care of ourselves.
Or too generous and not
It's a wonderful question.
It's a very important question.
And like a lot of these
really deep and important
personal questions for us.
Like there's absolutely a
line of what's too much.
When are we being complacent
rather than active?
When are we becoming
a doormat, because I'm
being compassionate
toward your suffering
so I'm going to let
you be unkind to me.
And I'm going to be
compassionate and forgiving.
There's absolutely
a line of when
we need to actually
speak up for ourselves,
and say no, and have
a good boundary.
But I don't know where that
line is for anybody else.
Because it's for each one of us.
It's our personal, where's
the balance here for me.
And so it's a lot of what the
mindfulness practice and all
of this conversation is about
is developing that intuitive
knowing of what's too much.
And I think we get there
from trial and error.
I think the only way that we
found our balance, our middle,
is through giving too
much, giving not enough,
forgiving, having compassion
in a way that's attached.
You know, that kind
of-- I had compassion.
I expected you to change.
[LAUGHTER]
Not having the good boundaries.
I think, my own experience is
that just the trial and error
of, oh, that didn't
work so well.
Let me try something different.
It's always this ongoing
experiment of finding balance.
Thank you so much.
I'm really happy to have
been here to share with you
and to represent for MBA.
And so a few minutes
here at the end,
Bill and I think Roger are going
to have a few things to say.
BILL DUANE: So
Some exciting news.
So first of all,
thank you, Noah.
[APPLAUSE]
BILL DUANE: So I have
some exciting, happy news.
So one is that, as
you know, gPause
has given in nice
chunk of change
to help MBA with its programs.
In addition, there
is the Google match.
And Meng and I are
also going to have
another match on top of that.
So if anybody would
like to go MBA project,
you can do the Google match.
And then send me an email,
and then Meng and I will also
match it up to $5,000 total.
So it's really nice opportunity.
And I think doing
is really important.
That's why more and
more of the gPause stuff
is about volunteering and
being in the community.
So there's also a
really fun project
that we've just posted on gGive
for a six month design project
to help them increase their
online and social network
presence.
So super fun there.
So I'll send out an email
with this information.
But it's the opportunity
to really take
some of the practices
and connection
that we were talking about
and sort of make it happen.
So that's an opportunity.
ROGER MILLER: So
I'm Roger Miller.
I'm the executive director
of the Mind Body Awareness
Project.
And just really want to
extend a lot of appreciation
and gratitude to Noah and
also Bill for hosting us here.
And certainly also you,
Meng, for your support.
And also just the general
Google and gPause community.
You all have been
fantastic, whether or not
you know it or not.
And we would love to get
more involved with Google.
This is such an amazing
giving and growing community.
We would love to
be more engaged.
And we're really
working a lot on trying
to improve some of
the digital products
that we're pushing into
the juvenile halls.
Some recordings of guided
meditations in the language
that the young people
speak to help them sleep
better, et cetera, at night.
And then also bringing that out
into the community to the youth
as they're trying to
transition back into the world,
and leaving the
safe or not so safe
cocoon of the juvenile hall and
returning to their communities.
We want to be with them with
some portable digital products
and app, and so
that's what we're
working on trying to develop.
NOAH LEVINE: I put some
flyers in the back.
I opened this drug and
alcohol treatment center
in Los Angeles, a
residential, that's
using meditation as the core
treatment for addiction.
So if you or anybody you know
might be interested in that--
BILL DUANE: A friend.
NOAH LEVINE: --there are flyers.
You or "a friend," yes.
I put some flyers back there.
If you have any questions
about it, happy to talk to you.
BILL DUANE: There's some
MBA schwag back there.
Oh, and if you do
donate, there's
a thing on gGive where
you can say, please share
my information with the group.
If you do that, they will send
you nice things, like prizes.
ROGER MILLER: T-shirts,
water bottles.
BILL DUANE: T-shirts,
schwag, We all love schwag,
stuff like that.
So reminder for that.
And I suppose, also
be on the lookout
for Still Chillin'
gPause sessions.
Sounds pretty good.
[LAUGHTER]
Cool.
Thank you all very much.
[APPLAUSE]